meagan Marco brought some American charm
to the British Royal Family's Christmas
morning
she joined fiance Prince Harry and other
members at the Queen's Sandringham
Estate outside London Daniella Ralph
of our partner station BBC is there well
good morning from the Queen's estate at
Sandringham where the royal family
traditionally come to spend Christmas
Day we've seen them this morning go to
church here it's at Mary Magdalene
Church the Queen driven up to the church
gates the rest of the royal family
walking from the main house and they're
in the midst of the royal family today
was megan Markel Prince Harry's fiance
walking arm-in-arm with her fiance into
the church it is the first time we have
seen Megan Markel as part of the wider
royal family in public her being here is
actually a break with protocol normally
you don't get the invitation to
Sandringham for Christmas with the Queen
unless you are already married but
because Megan Markel's immediate family
are in the United States it was felt
that an exception should be made this
year and she has been invited here to
spend Christmas with the Royals there
have been hundreds of people here to see
the royal family and plenty of Americans
among amongst them lots from some local
RAF bases you've come here to see what
many have called their own American
princess back to you Tony but first it's
time to check your local weather